man
what's up guys it's been a little while
can you guys hear me you guys should be
able to hear me right now hopefully
waiting for people to say yes what's
going on guys
are you guys able to hear me well max
where you going
loud and clear okay cool like nobody was
answering my question to get worried I
was like hey can you guys hear me and
all people everywhere all anybody's
thing is like I'm so excited this is
back you know and like no one's
answering my question
okay so so first things first is you
guys know for those of you guys who are
or yes this is max by the way this is my
dog max max is a Labrador slash hound
slash pitbull he has a lot of stuff
yo-yo parents but anyway yeah there's
usually always a delay hopefully it's
not too bad on the audio it's it's one
of those things with YouTube and Twitter
and OBS and and so on but yeah there's a
slew of the guys who aren't aren't used
to live streaming there's usually always
like a 5 to 10 second delay between what
you guys say and and you know when you
actually hear me reply to it the other
thing is we're so with what comes to
coffee what we used to do is it would
literally just be like an hour of me
answering questions about comic so
that's what this is gonna be I'll answer
questions about comics I am NOT
sponsored by polo but I'm also gonna
open this up with two things each each
of these of course how much the coffee
is only gonna be once per month now now
the reason why is because one of the
reasons like I burned down on doing it
before was because I was doing it every
week and people would basically just all
the things a boil down to the same
question like person versus person who
do you think you know and they were just
battle against one another and well I'm
monitoring my stream right now so if
they're the screens frozen it might be
something on your end but a lot of
people would just do like like vs. yet
like death battles you know and and it
kind of took away from the overall
purpose and so I brought it back when
I'm scaling it down to once a month so
it'll be once once every month that you
guys will see this but I'm also gonna
open it with with like you know info on
the channel so as you guys know I've
been I've been experimenting with you
guys
after I don't know if you know I've been
experimenting with you guys but I've
been experimenting with you guys
you guys will have noticed that there
have been a lot of uploads cranking out
on the channel and a lot of its just
kind of been testing the waters to see
what you guys are receptive to what you
guys are not receptive to what works
what doesn't work it's not a conflict
you guys don't really seem to care for
too much you know honestly I think it's
an okay story I was doing just to see
you know if there was an interest in you
know some of the older x-men stories
that are not like classic x-men stories
you know like you know the onslaught
saga or something like that by the way
we have coffee for the first time but
the whole purpose was to what's the test
so you know that's with DC rebirth I'm
getting I'm really getting to DC we
worth a lot more and it's it's the
writing on that is absolutely amazing
and so what I'm gonna do is I want to
have DC stories as backdrops and because
there's only like three or four comics
that I'm reading at the moment you know
I'm reading Batman I'm reading Superman
I'm reading the flash a handful of other
sort of reading the flash last night
because people on periscope said it was
so good and so I'm gonna keep these few
stories as a background so it'll like
every week it'll be Batman then next
week it'll be Superman the next week
it'll be you know something you know so
on and so forth it'll just be like a
different DC story in the background of
all my other videos every week that said
I need to get my schedule sorted out
with that said like character
discussions like like all the videos
that you guys are used to will stay
it'll just be in addition to that DC
stories in the background so I need to
build up the DC presence a little bit
more just because I feel like my my
channel haven't you know with the entire
premise of changing from Marvel
explained that comments explained being
DC you know more DC related content DC
contents been pretty scarce on my
channel so far so I need to definitely
beef up that presence a little bit more
plus you know um like DC rebirth is so
good so uh you know so anyways so why
you guys are while I'm waiting for your
all's questions to start popping and
hopefully you guys started asking
questions soon so the other thing I want
to do you know when I open up these
episodes of Commerce to coffee you guys
will notice that back there in the
those are the guys who are familiar with
the backdrop that I have the the flag is
missing and the flag is actually right
here and a lot of people have asked
about this flag they asked you know is
it because I served in the military or
something like that now these flags are
given out to people who passed away but
served in the military and this flag
belong to my dad now like no sound for
for oh no sound for the right here oh my
god I'm sorry guys hold on hold on let
me fix that let me fix that I think I
think I got this actually the sounds in
stereo is not in mono
hold on a second I think I think I got
this I think I can channel there we go
Mon oh oh oh my god the program has to
be restarted okay hold on one second
guys hold on I'll be right back okay I'm
back all right you're um you're right
ears should feel a whole lot better your
your ears should be better the delay is
something that I can't really do
anything about again that's that's a no
BS slash YouTube issue as far as I'm
aware not a whole lot I can do on that
so um anyway okay cool
I just came back alright so now it's fun
okay cool so your your ears should you I
have we do not discriminate here on
comics explained alright we treat left
and right ears equally we do not favor
one here over the other and therefore I
have rectified this issue of
discrimination I apologize for those
left ears that I may have where those
right ears that I may have discriminated
against it was not my intention
please forgive me anyway um all right so
let me recharge my I got my Magic Mouse
dies anyway so uh so yeah so this is
this is the American flag and it's given
to people who pass away that served in
the military now when my dad my dad
served in the Navy at his funeral
because we had a military funeral for
him which is usually where you get these
from
they had they gave it to my stepmom and
and it was it was it was kind of uh you
know it was kind of weird hash tag left
ears matter yeah it was it was kind of
interesting because she gave it to me
and and I didn't really know what to say
I was I was kind of left speechless
because I felt like it was something
that she should have had but she was
like your dad would have wanted you to
have this and so every time I like every
every no matter where I've moved because
I've really it was a lot I've only moved
once I moved here I always keep it on
display somewhere like somewhere where
it's easy to see for people who who walk
in and see it but um but yeah like that
is that's one of the most important
things I had to get a box need to get an
actual case for it so but yeah like it
was it was a line of military in my
family I'm the first one to break that
tradition my granddad was in the Air
Force my grandma was in the Air Force
that's how they met they both fought in
the Korean War my dad was in the Navy my
uncle was in the was in the Navy I don't
think we had anybody on our in our
family that was in the Army or the
Marines I think it was all just just
Navy and airforce but anyway yeah so
that's the story behind that no I did
not serve in the military I my dad tried
to get me to enlist I had no desire to
but shortly after I graduated like I
should when I was in high school shortly
after he and I had to talk about you
know he was like you should really think
about the military it'll give you some
discipline stuff like that 9/11 happened
the war on terror happened and I would
have been shipped overseas god only
knows what would have happened so um so
anyway so that that was that's that's
that whole that's that whole thing um
show you guys the setup you guys want to
see the Senate well the Senate was kind
of a wreck right now
I mean the camera is I can't really the
camera cord is part of my cable
management so I can't just take the
camera and show you guys but if it's any
consolation I can describe it
I've got a big 96 inch desk here it's a
pretty huge a desk I bought it on IKEA
and I have I have a Mac I have a Mac Pro
like a 2012 Mac Pro I thought about
getting 2013 Mac Pro but it seemed kind
of dumb it didn't seem to make any sense
by the way guys you should be asking
questions about comics that's what this
is for not not just general like what
are you baby god for those of you guys
are new here comments of coffee is
literally just just your chance to ask
me questions about comics what I think
and you know back max is right over
there
Max's is laying down the thing but um I
appreciate the condolences about my dad
guys I mean it's been you know a year or
so so I mean I appreciate that but what
mic do I use well I use a couple of
different mics actually that's a good
question let's we got some microphones
let's talk about
okay so over the history of my channel I
have used a lot of different microphones
I guess this is just going to be a
general QA I guess it's not going to be
like one particular thing whatever
that's fun I have used several different
microphones of the life of my over own
life of my channel I've used the blue
Yeti I think is what it is I don't even
really remember what it is anymore right
now I'm using the the Sennheiser II 8:35
this is the shure sm7b supposedly guys
who watch the mark of jay this is the
microphone he uses i am using the e or i
used to use the EVR e20 the
electro-voice
are you 20 this is the microphone that I
use when I'm doing a history of the
Marvel Universe because this is your a
broadcasting standard high end
professional microphone this was pricey
this was about 400 bucks but it's the
most expensive microphone that I ever
bought I bought it at the behest of a
friend of mine who's a sound and sound
engineer and he was like you should get
a super high-end microphone even if you
only use it you know only a handful of
times it makes all the difference like
if I auditioned for a voice work like
the voice audio that I'm gonna do for
what you might call it for the Mass
Effect Andromeda series will be done
using this so do I read indie comics yes
I read valiant and I read an image
haven't really gotten into that much you
know I haven't really gotten to like
Skybound or anything like that I've
heard that I should which I probably
should so yeah east of West is
hands-down my yeah the man with 5,000
hands the market J the east of West is
currently my favorite out of image with
with Jonathan Hickman mixes that's
because I'm not Hickman fan boy ps4 Xbox
actually I both but currently the ps4 is
hooked up right now by the way for those
of you guys who were interested I don't
don't like well I guess what I do
promotion at some point along the line
but there's a series that I have coming
out relatively soon where I'm gonna talk
about the history of the console wars it
won't be on
explained but but I'll keep you guys
posted on where it'll be yeah but it'll
be it'll be the history of the console
wars so I have not read Britannia
no I'm not returning yeah you auditioned
for Mass Effect a while back badass how
did it go I'm kind of curious well okay
so those of you guys who don't know
Bioshock is hosting a contest which it
ends on the 28th I think but you
basically download two scripts and you
read them both and then you just send in
the audio I assume you upload it to
YouTube to like a YouTube file or
something like that or whatever it is
but you just you send it out and you
know that's your audition for a
non-playable character I assume in Mass
Effect Andromeda have I ever said oh
partnering with an artist to create my
own comic um I thought about it a few
times you know I don't know it was it's
maybe interesting that the hardest part
to me would be writing this story like
if I were gonna write a story I'd want
to write a story about an existing
character because the the landscapes
already there somebody just kind of
remoulding it and changing it up because
I'm I know it sounds weird but I'm a lot
more creative when I have something to
work with you know if you sit clay in
front of me I can mold that clay into
something awesome not physically I don't
know the first thing about molding clay
but as an example if you sit clay in
front of me I can mold it into something
pretty awesome making the clay I'm not
so good at so what are your thoughts on
Civil War two issue number five I've got
a civil war to issue number five was
pretty good to me it's the overall issue
with civil war you know some word
somewhere one was good because it was
really it was lightning in a bottle to
be quite frank with you guys Marvel
caught lightning in a bottle with Civil
War and you can't duplicate it
you would they wouldn't be able to copy
that again I mean there's there's no way
that they could they could keep that
going is that stream frozen for anybody
else I don't know that's weird seems
like it's frozen
let's see
there we go cool um yeah I'm gonna watch
the Doctor Strange movie um was Civil
War - it was it was weird to me because
I felt like you know I felt like with
Civil War - that or with Civil War one
they caught lightning in a bottle
you could never duplicate that it was
the right story that came along at the
right time um it was basically you know
freedom versus Security income but for
him it was it was the post 9/11 world
argument in Caly book form and and it
made for some great storytelling because
it was planned out you know effectively
the issue with what you see right now in
in Marvel Comics is civil war is it's
even even if the first Civil War was a
crash about which it was it was made for
the purpose of making money
this one the Civil War - seems more of
an act of desperation than it does a
planned out story and the result is it
doesn't have the same impact it doesn't
have the same effect you know I feel
like they were trying to do what they've
already done and it just doesn't have
the same impact not to mention and
inhuman they can see the future is the
thinnest plot thread in the history of
the world so it's not very good how
funky fresh is Luke Cage funky fresh
very funky fresh what is my opinion on
the 2016 coming book movies released oh
man there's been some great movie see
right now is a great time to be a comic
book fan you know and I was kind of
thinking about this as almost because I
was going through the Marvel subreddit a
few days ago and I saw that there were
people who were asking questions
you know legitimate questions you know
or they were asking fun questions you
know like what if what if Peter Parker
had stayed married to Mary Jane Watson
or something like that and people were
downloading it now there was only a
small number of people who were down
voting and others would come back and
upload it you know but but you know I
don't like the idea of people that you
know kind of tear other people down for
asking something that's you know if
we're asking somebody interesting that's
a cool question you know I like that
kind of question we're simply asking you
know things that that are common
knowledge to us but are not common
knowledge to them our role right now
like at this moment right now our role
has color book fans as diligent cover
book readers is to literally help those
were not part of the comic book world
want to get into it find a way to get
into it like our job is to kind of teach
them you know how to get into these
things and I feel like coming but movies
really do a great job of that even if
they're not 100 percent true to you know
the story cover you know Captain America
Civil War was not 100 percent true to
the story but it was still a great movie
you know it's it's you know demon in a
bottle for example this the story arc
demon in a bottle war Tony Stark
basically hit rock bottom with his
alcoholism that was the underlying theme
of Iron Man one two and three but you
know it was never it wasn't true to the
story because obviously Disney would not
sanction a story where Tony Stark is an
alcoholic effectively like it's just
kind of blown out there in your face I'd
you know even Disney would kind of
sanction that despite the fact that they
kind of leave Marvel to do their own
thing but maxy those max guys I guess
anyone see max there's max but you know
like like Deadpool it's a really good
example Deadpool is a pop culture icon
you know there are people that have
never read a Deadpool comic in their
life where they love Deadpool because
they love the idea of such a goofy and
silly character there are people that
read his comics ever you know all when
they all come out and they own them all
they own the Joe Kelly run they own the
Christopher priest run they own the the
short-lived you know Rob Liefeld run
they own the circle chase by Mark Waid I
think it was they own every comic this
has been published by Deadpool and they
they love his character but but the
great thing is that Deadpool 2 movies
showed showed people showed casual kind
of book fans or you know perspective
comic book fans but not all comic books
are dark and not all superheroes fight
all the time you know sometimes are just
crazy people and they don't make sense
to anybody but themselves and Deadpool
is one of those guys but um it's uh max
but uh but yeah you know it's it's
interesting you know it's it's uh you
know the the runs of comic book movies
right now plus there's the animated
series you know the animated section
where you got you know The Killing Joke
the Killing Joke was great I mean I
really loved it I got a question for you
guys how many of you guys watched The
Killing Joke how many the guys saw The
Killing Joke
Max is God that's a great way to
alienate audiences honestly Max's Max's
neither Max is a Pokemon fan he has a he
has a Pokemon go hat yeah um I actually
have not really read injustice not the
biggest fan of injustice that ever
existed the the intro random caused me
happy right problems on about two
hundred and thirty eight issues if
they're gonna true in a thirty eight
videos so I chose not to watch it shows
how to use it okay those of you guys who
have watched it how many of you guys
think that Batman killed the Joker at
the end oh my god so many replies who's
the most powerful hero well what which
one are we talking about we talk about
Marvel are we talking about DC Marvel
the most powerful hero is it's a toss-up
a Franklin Richards can warp reality but
he's not a multiversal threat
he's a universal threat of all the
mutants he is a well I mean it's killing
jokes man it was it's been a story for
20 years guys you know of all the
mutants that have ever existed Franklin
Richards is the most powerful well no
Matthew Malloy is the most powerful they
had to travel into the past to like keep
them being born in order to defeat him
with non mutants let us say everybody
that's ever existed molecule man Owen
Reese is the most powerful because he's
a multiversal threat he his power
extends into the multiverse he can
manipulate you can manipulate molecules
anything that contains molecules he can
control whether it's space whether it's
planets stars the you know energies that
make up the dimensional barriers you
know I mean you can manipulate anything
he's literally he can control he can do
anything he wants to with anything he's
a head of the Living Tribunal and some
even speculated that before he was
retconned he was as powerful as the one
above all he was a wildly powerful
character who's my favorite in human
I guess blackbolt honestly I'm not
wildly knowledgeable about the Inhumans
I know the basis behind their creation
another history but in terms of the
events that kind of been going on right
now with the exception of Charles souls
in humanity you know I never really got
gets inhuman I never really got into
being humans series I'm curious what do
you guys think of Marvel replacing the
x-men with Inhumans I'm kind of curious
I'd like to know what your always
thought is on that a favorite DC Weber
series at the moment Superman rebirth I
feel like it's like it was needed
Superman rebirth was a much needed story
for Superman's character and here's the
reason why guys here's why Superman
needed some needed some much-needed
attention in the realm of DC Comics
Superman had struggled since like the
1950s I mean it was just he was carried
his comics just weren't very popular
because you know one there were so many
changes in the sense that you know when
more wiser he left Julie Schwartz wanted
to bring him more down to earth you want
to make him a more tame character but
Batman was becoming more popular
Batman was just like a guy that ran
around and beat up criminals but he had
gadgets he he was kind of dark he was
not really willing to go out and kill
all the time so much as he was willing
to subdue the hell out of criminals
using razor sharp batarangs you know he
was he was uh he was a more relatable
character and so you know especially
after the death of Superman when they
killed off Superman people were like oh
my god they killed off Superman like
like we're part of this massive comic
book event it's it's insane you know and
because they killed him off you know
here's kind of book sold like
gangbusters well you know the more
people bought then the less they were
worth and so I kind of led to the comic
book busts of the 1990s and when they
brought him back people were like no I
thought Superman was dead like I thought
we were part of this huge incredible
event like nothing we'd ever seen before
why did you bring him back and they they
brought him back and the result was that
as his sales tanked after that people
felt betrayed they were like you know
what fine like if if you're just going
to kill characters and then bring them
back on
you know then of what relevance is
anymore and so they ended up abandoning
Superman you know and and so his sales
just never really recovered going into
the new 52 people were expecting you
know the Superman they they were you
know that they remembered you know
forever they expected the
larger-than-life the guy that always
does the right thing Superman and it
said they got the young unexperienced
emotional Superman that people didn't
like and so his sales tanked you know
even further they continued to just be
bad and you know a Superman rebirth you
know it is it's a great return to the
Superman that we all know and love is
like Superman rebirth feels what it
feels like what Superman the new 52
should have been to be honest now I know
that there are a lot of people out there
that love the new 52 Superman and I can
see where you're coming from but for me
you know it was always the old school
shout-out to Wes Wes what's up no idea
who Wes is but uh you know to me the
old-school Superman is is the Superman
you know but who's my favorite speedster
the Wally West Wally West had so much
character development Barry Allen is
cool why are people asking for a shout
out to Wes I have no idea who that is
but you know Barry Allen's cool but
Wally West had some incredible
development
how would I fix the x-men today ooh I've
not played 2k 17 Wesley Snipes Max's
love Max's life how would I fix the
x-men today I don't know that would take
some thinking because they've they've
literally scattered their comics to the
winds they basically driven them into
the ground you know I don't know that
would take some thinking uh who's the
most powerful Mexican super villain
massacre the Mexican Deadpool shout out
to West how powerful is a Silver Surfer
okay so the silver surfers powers he's
like a lot of comic book characters come
up with characters go lactis or you know
apocalypse or somebody like that
they have powers where their powers wax
and wane based on what happens you know
what what the what the rider wants to do
but if we take Silver Surfer at the peak
of his power so we take him in the 1990s
you know the absolute peak of his
abilities he is not as powerful as
Galactus but he's still relatively close
um I mean it's it's you know a far cry
Macready's oh he's a far cry from what
Galactus is capable of but he's still in
the top you know 10 most powerful beings
in the universe
barring cosmic entities he I mean he was
able to time-travel he was able to
manipulate the molecules of anything he
touched of anything he saw um he could
take and give powers to people he could
take powers away he could he could you
could do a lot of different things he
was wildly powerful favorite rebirth
book yeah Superman definitely Superman
Superman rebirth having said that I say
Superman rebirth because I really
haven't had a chance to read Batman and
the Dark Knight or I'm sorry Detective
Comics or flash
I'm actually reading those today and
I'll let you guys know I'll post on
Twitter like you guys know which one I
dig the most let's see
adidas or Nike Nike who would pick
indeed is over Nike that's crazy talk
well there's nowhere else to go with
Hitman's fantastic for me like I said
here's here's a deal guys with Hitman's
fan has like four it is a great story
and there is more to within that like
like you you find out later on that when
the Council of reads was destroyed that
a lot of the dooms that were lobotomize
stay there and Doctor Doom went to the
Council of reads location and like he
does like this a really cool moment he
sits down on a chair and he's like I can
build here and so like all the
lobotomized dooms where their allegiance
to Doctor Doom like to the main doctor
noon um which if I remember correctly
actually God would probably should have
included that because if I remember
correctly I think he used that as a base
of operations during seeker wars I don't
remember if that's the case or not but
there's a conversation between Galactus
and Franklin Richards the adult Franklin
Richards Orgel actus is like I had no
clue that your powers would get to this
point where you could make me a herald
where you would be a universal construct
you know you would be as powerful as
anybody could ever be he was like I
didn't realize your powers would get to
that place and he was like you know they
mentioned something about a Galactus
seed which I don't know I don't know if
you guys know what I'd like to see
there's I think I explained it in there
but but he was like you know you know he
says we will stand until the destruction
of all things until the universe
collapses which is what happened during
the multiverse there were the last two
remaining individuals they were the last
two beings alive and that was that was
kind of it like like the adult Franklin
Richards did exist during sneaker Wars
like there was you know had been tied
into him he was there you know and both
him and Galactus were the last two
surviving beings that made it out alive
we're didn't really make out alive but
who's explained God's people as far as I
know have they finished that Godspeed
story arc yet because I don't know if
they just finished it or not but I guess
I should do flash Godspeed
um let's see Ben Affleck your Christian
Bale how strong would world break her
Hulk be if he had a Lantern ring oh god
he be I don't know I mean he was he was
strong enough to lay waste to virtually
everybody on earth I do not know exactly
how strong he would be with a Lantern
ring I mean you got to think I mean if
he was able to create constructs but see
here's here's the difference though the
Lantern rings are contingent on the
imagination of its wielder The
Incredible Hulk is not wildly
intelligent um now if we were talking
about professor Hulk I think it was
where he had the brain of of Bruce
Banner but he had the strength of the
whole well then he'd be wildly powerful
he'd be a universal threat but if you're
just talking about World Recor Hulk if
he had a Lantern ring he'd be able to
create simple constructs but he wouldn't
be wildly as powerful you know yeah I
guess now if he had rage if he if he
allowed the race to consume him in its
entirety and he just basically turned
into a mindless beast with the power of
the Red Lantern ring then he would be a
that he'd be a universal threat of the
highest order because there's no telling
what he would create with his what kind
of constructs who would like there'd be
no telling he'd be operating with a
primitive mindset but capable capable of
using the Red Lantern ring but also have
strength that that's limited only by his
rage and so like the like literally the
angrier he gets the stronger he gets so
one he'd be stronger than virtually
anybody in the universe if they pushed
him if they made him angry well yeah
because the Red Lantern ring of Rage
would heighten his height in his rage so
that would make him yeah he'd be
probably the strongest the physically
strongest being in existence able to
take on probably cosmic entities in a
physical form I mean go like characters
like Galactus and guys like that could
still just phase him out of existence it
would just be like gone but barring that
we don't enter you know keeping out
cosmic entities I can just white him out
of existence he would probably kill the
entirety of the
marvel universe to be honest with you
yes do I think the century should come
back to all-new all-different no I don't
think so
I think century was a great concept for
what he was at the time the century you
see my issue I love the centuries
original series by Paul geing as a
jaylee but the century never should have
been used beyond that the century should
have just stayed and this should have
been the limit of it you know it was
Marvel Knights that should have been the
the extent of it you know because the
way the punching in to end of the story
he went back to his normal life and the
world went back to forgetting about him
they actually had to kind of force him
into the main Marvel Universe when Joe
Quesada robbed you know brought
everything about everything over yeah I
know the audio is off god there's a
delay between OBS and YouTube not a
whole lot I can do about it but let's
see yeah it's it's it would have been
better you know if he had just kind of
stayed you know with the the Marvel
Knights series so let's see do you I do
I prefer Marvel or DC well you know if
this was six or seven months ago I would
have said Marvel but DC we birth is
getting me more into DC and so I
definitely love you know I I love I'm
not the biggest fan of what they're
doing with all-new all-different marvel
I can kind of see where they're going
with it
but I'm definitely digging DC because of
DC rebirth now so the most underrated
hero damn underrated hero
I don't know see with DC you can't
really do underrated heroes because they
do character story arts and so they tell
you they spend all the time in the world
fleshing out their characters they don't
really do like huge crossover events and
if they do it they you know it's it's
not an insane thing you usually find
underrated heroes and Marvel Comics I
wouldn't say he's a hero because he's a
bad guy but I'd say the most underrated
character in Marvel Comics is probably
graviton graviton graviton is under the
name Gravitron whatever it is graviton I
think is his name the guy that controls
gravity I'd say he's probably the most
underrated character because of how
powerful he is being able to control
gravity like he's pretty badass
what days am I gonna be in New York
Comic Con we're gonna be there from the
from the 5th through the 9th I think but
if you guys follow us on twitter follow
me a comic store of not comic story if
calling me a comments explained follow
Benny a comic story and Sal at
counter-clock or South says what Joel at
cave Joel you'll will post online
well like will tweet out you know when
our stuff is gonna be and you guys will
be able to meet us so graviton okay cool
I can never remember I always keep
confusing between Gravitron and graviton
so anyway
ah let's see what do you think the Joker
is I promise I won't set you in a circle
to answer this no it's fine
here's my question they haven't
explained the three Joker's story have
they because I know that in DC rebirth
or Batman rebirth I think they they
didn't they stated that the whole three
Joker's thing is still in existence but
they haven't actually explored that I
don't know to be honest I mean I think
they're picking the three most popular
Joker's in the history of Batman's
continuity and they're just kind of
rolling with those three different
Joker's from three different timelines I
think it I think it's gonna tie into the
whole ten years gone event I think it's
gonna tie in a document hadn't maybe a
few other things I don't know but uh
yeah I don't know why perfect honestly I
prefer the notion that the Joker is just
a crazy guy like I prefer that I prefer
that idea the whole idea of drinking
from that from that liquid that weird
you know stuff that was below Gotham you
know and haven't been alive for two
hundred years it's that's an interesting
concept I like that Scott Snyder was
kind of creating it as like an eternal
battle between good versus evil but I
prefer the Joker just being a guy that
just had a really bad day and just
became a crazy person you know yeah so
do I think Marvel will be doing a reboot
honestly I don't think so I think
Marvel's too stubborn to do a reboot to
be honest with you guys
dynasty and there we go dining scene yes
Dionysian uh have I seen Robbie Rhea's
ghostrider in ages of shield do I like
it yes um I thought Robbie Reyes was
done extremely well in agents of shield
here's the reason why
one of the biggest concern I had is that
the budget for Robbie Reyes for the
ghost writer concept the flaming skull
you know fire and all that kind of stuff
it wasn't gonna be very high because at
the end of the day one thing you guys
are got to keep in mind is DC or
Disney's are not throwing a ton of money
behind you know the ages of shield TV
show it's there you know and it's it's
something that exists but they're not
throwing a ton of money behind it which
makes sense I mean you know but my fear
was they were gonna blow the entirety of
their budget on his skull being on fire
and the rest of the story was going to
suffer we saw a flaming skull from him
twice the first time was kind of you
know a little bit like you know when you
first see it all you see is kind of a
silhouette in the background but you
could easily make it fit into everything
else
the other half people tell me my voice
is amazing all the time I appreciate it
the other half is the other time was we
saw his flaming skull up close and the
fact that we only saw it a couple times
but they focused on the mythology behind
him is a cool thing because what's
really interesting is they painted him
as like a Punisher s character in
daredevil season 2 you know The Punisher
was like this guy who was just laying
waste to the gangs of Hell's Kitchen
there's like my favorite team you know
where where where Matt Murdock asked the
one guy he pulls him off the meathook
and he's like who did this like who were
you know who did this to you you know
where are they and the guys like no they
one man it was just one man and I was
like oh my god that's so cool then it
switches to the scene where he's walking
through the hospital you know chasing
down that one guy you know at the same
time you know there was there was the
whole idea of you know with Ghost Rider
he's in this neighborhood and it's like
you know they say that when the rider
comes for you there's no escape and I
love that you know cuz it's like it's
like there's it tells you there's like
this undercurrent you know there's this
this nameless fear in in the Marvel
Universe ranging
the Punisher to a ghostwriter you know
and this whole idea of shield and you
know Captain America and Iron Man and
that's the very top but at the very
bottom there are some serious things
going on and and I really dug yeah I
really like Robby Reyes it's a huge
answer to the question that you asked
but yeah it was it was pretty awesome
let's see
did you read Watchmen and what are your
thoughts yeah I read Watchmen it's an
interesting story I agree with you know
Ozymandias but yeah let's see uh who's
your favorite Green Lantern mine is Jon
Stewart uh uh or yours is Jon Stewart my
favorite Green Lantern is Hal Jordan I
got to go with the classic
I got to go with Hal Jordan I know
there's a lot of people that love Kyle
Rayner but I'm a stickler for tradition
you know and in comics and I loved the
the rise and fall of Hal Jordan you know
I loved how he became parallax you know
and then he was he was that weird stent
where he was the the the specter I'm not
really sure I feel that you know but I
like that he's just kind of he's like
he's like the one guy when it when it
all goes to pot what it all comes
crashing down when the when everything
is it's coming to an end
you know how Jordan is always the one
guy left who's like we got to do this
guys Andy where's everybody else I love
I love how Jordan that he's a great
character let's see who do I think dr.
oz is I think he's awesome and yes from
the watchman to be honest with you guys
how many think I just think that dr. oz
is Ozymandias is Superman immortal in
terms of in terms of longevity
yes in terms of his powers yes can he be
killed yes so it's kind of a it's kind
of a quagmire I guess I wouldn't say
he's an immortal so much as he's
extremely long-lived but I don't know it
depends I mean do you take the Superman
prime route like do you believe that you
know in a million years that he'll be in
the Sun you know do you believe the hill
he'll have gotten that powerful I have
no idea but am i excited about the
Doctor Strange movie absolutely
you think he's Lex Luthor that'd be a
good maybe not actually see that would
be a damn good plot turn if it turned
out that dr. Oz was actually Lex Luthor
that would be interesting
I would dig that yeah Luke Cage in five
days guys Luke Cage in five days I'm so
excited about the new method locate one
no Luke Cage is on the xxx I think so it
comes out in like seven days I believe
what is today I don't have my phone
I'm very hyped for Luke Cage I can't
wait to watch it
I definitely Picard in day a week you
think he's the pre new 52 Lex Luthor
that would be cool let's see what the
penance stare work on Darkseid or lex
luthor ooh that'd be an that'd be
interesting I don't know that's an
interesting question with a penance
stare word I don't think it'll work on
Darkseid
I think Darkseid would be able to
counter it you know using his Omega
sanction or something like that Lex
Luthor yes I think so
because Lex Luthor aside from his
intelligence has no powers and so I
think it would work on him that question
the question being though okay I'm sorry
I take that back
Ghost Rider would be able to
successfully force Lex Luthor to look at
him what looks Luthor actually feel bad
like what do you feel pain maybe I don't
know I have no idea because I don't know
if he's if he's just I don't know I mean
does he feel remorse for the things that
he does you know like what do you feel
bad I have no idea
favorite superhero TV series the flash
that was never in question the flash is
hands-down the best comic book TV series
going right now right now it is the best
comic book TV series nothing comes close
to the flash it's incredible I am now
that man
I have been watching Dragon Ball super
okay those are guys who were watching
Dragon Ball super
I think Goku black is well I guess they
already established it that um
Saitama whatever his name is just wished
for an evil version of Goku but but yeah
Punisher possibly on Ages of shield okay
I read that article all article all that
article says is agent of shield is
getting darker the Punishers dark I
guess it makes sense he be on there like
that's that's all that article says and
so is it's it's 100% speculation with
not a single iota of evidence to verify
it's it's it's a cool concept but I was
always going into the article expecting
you know some some you know Hamas who
that's what it is I was expecting some
you know information or something like
that
Super Saiyan Rose what's going on y'all
welcome to rob Super Saiyan Emporium we
got all kinds of super sink oh we got
Super Saiyan turquoise we got Super
Saiyan red lipsticks
we got Super Saiyan Rose we got all the
Super Saiyan colors you could possibly
mean we even got Super Saiyan
mix-and-match colors make your own color
they're just they're just swinging for
the fences with these Super Saiyan
colors now man but let's see what do you
think of clones like what do you mean
clones as then like the Clone Saga not
really sure what you mean
what Hickman's story would fit best with
the MCU definitely Fantastic Four or
shield but shields still not finished
man let's see man questions are pouring
in now it's crazy
Punisher versus Batman that story
actually exists
let's see Batman year one Netflix series
oh yes I would read the hell out of that
Batman year one Netflix yes definitely
um let's see Super Saiyan Rasta
Lacombe conspiracy I think it's just a
repeat of the Clone Saga I think that's
all that is yeah for example like for
those of you guys II see here's here's
one of the issues like for those of you
guys who are going through all-new
all-different marvel they're sorting
enemy of the state with x-23 s wolverine
or i guess i guess i'll new all
different wolverine enemy in the state
was a story that already existed and it
was when Wolverine was kidnapped in
brainwashed by the hand in hydra and
started just attacking all the super
heroes of the world now there is a story
there's a what-if story which I actually
covered Wolverine kills the Marvel
Universe well where the brainwashing
never wears off and the result is that
he actually goes through and kills
everybody from the superhero community
kills Captain America the whole nine
yards he kills them all so let's see
that's awesome who won in Punisher vs
Batman uh I don't remember
let's see god there's so many questions
rolling in it's hard to keep track of
them all Adam warlock MCU your thoughts
on it it definitely makes sense to me
he'd be I don't know if they're gonna
have him in here though
like and maybe he'll appear in infinity
war I'm not sure we saw us cocoon and
it's like who broke open but we have no
idea what they ever did with him
Superman versus dr. Manhattan that's
gonna make for a badass battle and I
really want to see that because it's pre
new 52 Superman there's nothing for you
to choose to man pre new 52 Superman is
a lot stronger than the new 52 version
and so so I definitely kind of
definitely I'd dig that um personally I
still think dr. Manhattan takes it but
you know it depends on what kind of
powers they give him it depends on what
abilities he may or may not have
honestly I'd like to see the Superman
when but no it's fine if all the
questions roll and I just kind of catch
the ones this is one of the things I
learned when I first sort of Commerce
and coffee is you're not gonna be able
to answer every question because they
all will end so fast you just kind of
catch them you know catch the ones you
can and go with it from there
so yes I'm on a Mac right now let's see
what's my favorite childhood TV show
David the gnome hands down I'm like I
love David enough my favorite video
games Star Wars night - the Old Republic
one that was a great game right after
that I guess the super warrior world so
any expectations of the Legion TV show
well as far you know if what the rumor
mill is choking out a turning out is to
be believed he will be like it'll be
part of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
don't know if that's true or not and we
won't know until the series comes out
but or until it just gets tied in
somehow they've already referenced him
being the most powerful mutant they've
ever encountered so they're already
talking about how insanely powerful he
is so they're obviously gonna go with
the route of all the different
personalities of Legion each one having
a different power honestly it depends on
who they write you know the the
frameworks already there I mean the
framework to make a great Legion TV show
is there they have all the material that
they need it just comes down to can fox
or can't FX actually write something
good out of it that said FX has really
been bad about their own individual
shows their own particular shows they
they're actually you know pretty solid
like they're pretty good so um let's see
uh am i excited for Doctor Octopus
returning in comments I guess honestly I
liked him in spider-man I preferred
superior spider-man how many of you guys
like to superior spider-man I loved it
like I liked him in Peter Parker's body
granted it's not a long term story arc
you can't keep it forever you know but I
think he's better when he's trying to
redeem himself to be quite frank because
it adds a whole new dynamic to him so
let's see favorite coffee brand hashtag
selling out
definitely Folgers folders is my
favorite coffee brand so the strain is
amazing yeah favorite rebirth titles so
far it's Superman but I'm getting ready
to start on Batman and the flash so
favorite Scott Snyder story um
quarter bowels just because it was a
creation of a whole new whole new
character
whole new villain and I loved I love the
court of owls tutorial I love the idea
that Batman had been operating in Gotham
and didn't know the court of owls was
there he suspected him I gave up on it
earlier and believed it was a myth but
they were able to operate without Batman
ever truly knowing they were alive that
you know that I think was one of the
coolest parts of Snyder's Snyder's
writing so Bendis needs and now he
doesn't he that let's see what can you
buy my book um actually here let me post
the link to it let me post the link to
it which I probably should have done
like a shot of the beginning of the
thing but you know I've already got a
video dedicated that went out yesterday
I don't want to bombard you guys with
too many posts because then people will
just stop caring
let's see you guys can buy my book for
those of you guys who don't know about
my book I wrote a book on the entire
history of this Superman so you could
buy there then also posted here down and
the comment down in the description
right now I think it's on sale for like
11 bucks or something along those lines
so I think I don't remember I believe I
believe I believe yeah so it's like it's
11 bucks you know so if you guys if you
guys refresh your live streams if you
refresh your video you guys will see the
link to my book down in the description
so you guys should all refresh and you
guys should all click on the link to
that book so let's see what do you think
of the future of trunks
the future of trucks is interesting I'm
glad they brought it back to be honest
like I'm glad they reintroduced it uh
let's see
yes you can buy it on Amazon um so many
questions do I think they'll have the
desert spider-man story in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe I don't know I kind
of hope so and to be honest I think I
think they'll do that eventually and
they'll bring in Miles Morales cuz I you
know if they're gonna have spider-man of
course you got to start with Peter
Parker you can't not start with Peter
Parker you got to go with him first and
then just fold it over into you know the
death of or I guess the you know then
role in Miles Morales let's see I don't
watch Rick and Morty let's see so many
see now there's like 570 people here so
there's so many people watching right
now so many questions rolling in I'm
trying to find a DC question Superman
versus action and rebirth okay so that's
that's the kicker so so here was
something that I apparently I had
misgivings about this you know my
apartments like like 1400 square feet I
had some I I apparently had
misunderstood this this whole thing so
it used to be at one point that Superman
in Action Comics both told the same
story but they told the story from two
different perspectives apparently what
they're doing in DC we birth is they're
both telling two different stories like
Action Comics is one story Superman is
another story which I didn't realize
that and so so I was I had kind of
assumed that it was gonna be tie into
the existing Superman story arc of son
of Superman but now I like apparently
it's not and so now I've got to go
through and read Action Comics 2 so so I
have not read action comics yet but I
need to
see the purpose of the book covers the
whole history of Superman from the time
he was created up until the new 52 so
thoughts on the upcoming TV show by Hulu
runaways I've never a big fan of
Runaways to be honest guys I could never
get into Runaways so any opinion on
titans rebirth I've not read Titans
rebirth yet for right now I'm just kind
of sticking to the big three I'm
sticking to Batman Superman Wonder Man
yeah Wonder Woman
by the way Trinity is amazing for those
of you guys who have not read Trinity
yet that is an amazing book it's it's a
beautifully done book I absolutely loved
it
but how can you get my book autographed
come out to New York Comic Con and
you'll definitely get it autographed if
you're not if you're not gonna be at New
York Comic Con what I might do is I
might set up a peel box where you can
send your book in and then also like
I'll autograph it and send it back to
you guys
let's see Batman versus that okay I
missed that
let's see Tiffany versus Benny I want to
see that personally I think Tiffany wins
I think Tiffany would take it what's
going on
JJ gamer show Titans is really good okay
I'll have to check that nothing well
I'll be at Comic Con on Thursday yeah I
think so
I think we we have I think we have stuff
planned out on what it is that we're
gonna do so we'll send a bunch of stuff
out if we can you know let you guys know
where we're gonna be at and well we'll
keep we'll keep you guys posted on
Twitter so um top three artist writer
combos uh Jonathan Hickman Assad Riddick
J michael Straczynski Assad Riddick and
Mark Waid Alex Ross definitely
uh-huh
yeah my apartments pretty big it's
pretty nice uh my faith is pretty good
oh my god questions are just flooding in
are there any superheroes that everyone
loves but I don't spider-man not the
biggest fan of spider-man but people
love him so let's see why is Vinny sort
of addicted oh no no no okay what are
the things you guys got to keep in mind
is that when it comes to the weekly poll
like we've got our own little brand
things that kind of you know create some
that create our own little thing Joel is
it the Vinny and Joel thing is it's
their own thing you know we've we've
already hit up Joel like definitely off
the podcast and we were like hey man
just to make sure like you're are you
all right and he's like yeah dude it's
fine this it's part of the whole it's
part of the whole thing don't worry like
if it becomes an issue then yeah it's
yeah don't worry guys it's not it's not
a huge thing um let's see why do I not
like spider-man
um because to me finally doesn't really
offer much I mean his stories aren't
really that interesting to me you know
his aside from his spider sense he's got
no real spectacular abilities I just
don't really care for him too much he's
just not really it's not really up my
alley
let's see but I like cosmic level
characters like I like characters that
are that are super capable so spider-man
what's cool in civil war I'll give him
that he was pretty cool too Civil War is
there anything else as good as Jonathan
Hickman seeker for Jonathan aim is
fantastic for there are a handful of
stories from both Marvel and DC that are
as good as Hickman's Fantastic Four well
not from Marvel I don't know hmm like
Kingdom Come is a really good story that
I would easily put on par with Hickman's
Fantastic Four Hitman's Avengers New
Avengers
okay for those of you guys who were avid
DC readers what DC stories would you say
are as good as Jonathan Hickman
Fantastic Four uh I am NOT playing final
fantasy 15
oh no no this out yet Ultimates I would
say Batman's a greatest detective
Chrissy's got the mind and the money
favorite non Marvel or non DC character
hmm probably tell your Harada from
Valiant Comics because he's so
identifiable flashpoint dark night
watchman nightfall The Killing Joke Luke
Cage oh no so that's different let's
just say character so he said Luke Cage
Tower of Babel was really good I see I
never read identity crisis I know what
it's about
blackest night yeah geoff johns entire
run of Green Lantern I would say let's
see I could never get into Raven I try I
read Raven number one the release of
rebirth I really couldn't get into it to
be honest
Lucifer Morningstar uh fast went off to
do his own modeling gig he's taken off
to do his own thing Grant Morrison's
Batman when invincible Harbinger well
harbinger wars was really good I really
dug Harbinger Wars all-star Superman is
super good
I did not intend for a pun to be there
anyway guys all right well we're hitting
it about the alum arc so we're gonna go
ahead I'm gonna go ahead and bounce off
here again this is a once a month thing
so this is this is really you know we'll
be back I guess at the end of October
near the end of October and yeah so so
thanks for coming out guys um you know
definitely make sure you guys check out
the description you know for the book
for Superman and yeah so I guess I'm
gonna go ahead and and and bounce off
here and I will see you guys in a month